one of the hearings i chaired we had
testimony from a guy
uh named named dr epstein oh yeah i know
about it
um and he's a psychologist used to be
the editor of psychology today
he's an academic he's by the way not a
conservative he's a liberal democrat
who voted for hillary clinton and openly
supported hillary clinton and
and he did empirical research
on google's manipulative search outcomes
so it's interesting psychology
when you type in a search the
autocorrect
the auto fill in not the autocorrect but
what automatically populates
makes a huge difference
um and the first few stories that come
up
make a huge difference and there was a
dramatic differential
between when you typed in hillary
clinton it would auto populate goods
yeah all good things
when you typed in donald trump it would
auto populate bad things and the stories
that would come up
would be predominantly good stories for
hillary predominantly bad stories
uh for trump and what was interesting is
is
dr epstein did the study and he
concluded that in 2016
google's uh deceptive
search outcomes shifted 2.4
million votes to hillary clinton
and he said this as a hillary clinton
supporter but he was he was horrified
but he also
projected he said in 2015 he said big
tech
is getting worse it's getting more
aggressive they could move as many as 15
million votes
to the democrats in 2020 and and so i
think it's a
huge threat
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell so that you
may be just maybe actually see our
videos in your feed
and joining me today is a republican
senator from texas the co-host
of the verdict podcast and a man who
uses almost as many
star wars references on twitter as i do
senator ted cruz
welcome to the reuben report dave it's
great to be with you and i will say i'm
i'm learning already as you start with
telling people to subscribe on youtube
so i'm a much
newer youtuber and podcaster and so and
so that
that that is is is good tutelage yes
well i'm going to need you in the senate
to fight the battles that i have been
fighting
on uh on youtube for quite some time
uh all right so we're obviously going to
get into big tech i also should mention
we're dressed
virtually exactly the same which is a
little weird but you've
rocked the uh well and look i i told you
we need to these are lucasy ostrich
which
uh are uh tough to beat and i've had
these resold
several times but they're they're good
uh
all right here's something interesting
we're talking a minute ago about how you
grew up in
in new york do you know where i started
wearing cowboy boots
well i'm gonna guess new york for some
reason or maybe new jersey
why jersey jersey cowboy boots what it's
it's a weird story so
so i grew up in houston i i and in
houston but i was
you know as a sort of junior high and
high school kid
was kind of a preppy kid for a while had
long hair had a spike
for a while i mean went through these
different phases
but you know i was a city boy and so i
didn't wear boots
in school growing up and then i went to
college at princeton in new jersey and i
was 17
and i was away from home and i just got
home sick
and so i said all right i'm gonna go buy
a pair of boots and it was sort of a way
for a 17 year old to kind of
hold on to your home and so i started
wearing boots as a freshman in college
and i've worn them ever since but it
took going to new jersey which is a
little ridiculous
to start wearing so you were basically
the texas boots guy at princeton
university
so i remember i had a a car
that that that my grandfather had given
me it was a 78
ford fairmont we called it the green
bomb and i remember
digging that car out of the snow using
the heel of my boots which by the way
doesn't work very well it's a really
like
bad idea but as a texas teenager i
didn't know anybody we got it out but it
was
but here we are all right moving on from
boots for a moment the one other
important thing that we have to get to
before all the issues
the beard situation because i think like
me you've now become more beard than man
at this point
something something happened when how
long you've had the beard about like a
year and a half maybe a year and a half
something like that
thanksgiving two years ago okay so about
two years
something happened to me when i got the
beard which is about three years ago or
so
i sensed the change in me do you sense
that change you seem to have gotten a
little
a little more feisty on twitter since
the beard is there a connection
there's a little bit of just kind of
screw it and then i mean that uh all
right so what prompted why'd you grab
the beer
i go off the grid every august i shut
down no phone no tv
nothing no no news and it's i've done it
for three years i'm about to do it in a
couple weeks
and the first time i did it i just
decided not to shave i came back
everybody said they love the beard and
then
you know it took over like black
spider-man i know you're also a
video comic book guy yeah so actually my
beard story is very much the same it was
thanksgiving i mean holidays i never
shave and so i would always sort of grow
a little bit of stubble during holidays
and just kind of over thanksgiving i
said all right pack with it i'm not
going to show you but it was it was not
you know there was no profound statement
it was just kind of like
this will be interesting and then
twitter likes it and you pretty much
have to
you know bow to the mob the the guy who
runs my political operation he emailed
me when i came back and his email was
like
worst idea ever so i had to be like
all right to heck with you i then i'm
definitely keeping it yeah you're also a
simpsons guy i mean we could do every
reference
basically every 80s and 90s reference we
could just set aside politics and do
that the whole time
i don't think i've seen twitter get more
angry
than when i said a couple of years ago
that i thought
every character but lisa simpson
was right of center that homer marge
barton maggie
are all conservatives and libertarians
and lisa is the the self-righteous
leftist and what was interesting i look
i was mostly just kind of riffing
yeah yeah but the twitter world went
nuts like
they could not handle and they're like
don't you understand lisa's the hero and
i'm like yeah except she's
self-righteous and criticizing everyone
in a pain in the ass
look homer is every man yeah i mean he's
he's basically a libertarian right yeah
bart clearly is a libertarian
i mean that maggie do you remember the
episode maggie is in the ein rand school
for tacos oh yeah
and then they do the great escape music
and she she escapes from it so i'm i'm
calling maggie
and by the way maggie's also a gun owner
because she shot mr burns
so so you know and then all right marge
yeah so marge that's the tough one here
but look
marge is she's traditional she's
traditional she's the anchor of the
family
she keeps she keeps everyone together
she gets homer to be a good dad
marge is the one that there's the fewest
indicia but it
the left hates when anything in pop
culture
they want to own it all yeah um and so
you know it's good to have fun
now that we've gotten the important
stuff out of the way let's talk about
big tech
because you've been right in the center
of this thing as you know i've been
fighting it from my
from my garage for the last five years
uh trump did this executive action
uh 230 is the is the what do you call it
it's not it's not a bill it's a
so it's section section of a bill called
communications decency
right so basically what he did was strip
some protections from the big boys from
twitter
youtube and facebook now my personal
preference and i think we're pretty
close on this
the libertarian side is you don't want
the government running around sending
regulators to these companies because
that's not going to do good
but stripping protection protections
to me seemed like the right idea do you
agree
was the right idea is it enough is it
not enough et cetera
so i think it is the right idea um it's
something i'd been
urging trump to do for three years so
i'm glad that the administration did it
um listen i agree with your sensibility
nobody wants
government free speech police i mean
that that would be a terrible outcome
well some people do
but nobody
who's not insane and that's a qualifier
we can talk about some more because
there are a lot of people that fall into
that category but government free speech
police would be a terrible outcome
but what big tech is doing
it's deliberate it's conscious it's
naked
it's abusive and it's dangerous i think
it's the single biggest threat
to free speech and democracy we have in
this country
because big tech has become a monopoly
controlling the instruments of
communication and
you know i've chaired multiple hearings
in the senate on big tech censorship
and one of the hearings we talked about
a document that google had prepared it's
called the good sensor
so they prepared its power points about
50 page long
and it talks about how the old vision of
the internet
was the free speech laissez-faire
internet where people could speak and
say what they wanted
and then it talked about the new vision
of the internet and this is google's own
words
is the european style censorship model
and by the way the four companies that
google identified as implementing it
were google youtube facebook and twitter
this is a conscious decision and and the
dangers are enormous so the question is
how do you fix it
if it is a problem we have a long
discussion about whether it's a problem
although
they're not hiding it anymore yeah i
think most sane
people at this point would agree that
there even even people that disagree
with us politically on this
i think most people realize that the
extraordinary amount of power
is a problem one way or another so i
will
it's interesting the political debate
though one of the talking points of big
tech in the left
is they don't engage in censorship and
the reason they say that is they say
well there are no
objective data that prove we do
and it's you know there's the old
aphorism of the of the
guy who kills his parents and then
pleads mercy on the court because he's
an orphan
it's true there are no objective data
because big tech controls all the data
and they zero transparency zero
accountability so you can use
anecdotes and i i've gone through lots
and lots of specific anecdotes
but every time you ask big tech and i've
done it in writing i've done it in
hearings
simple questions um all right in the
2018 election cycle
how many posts from republican
candidates for office did you block or
shadow ban
how many posts from democratic
candidates for office did you block or
shadow ban
their objective answers to that i mean
there is a number yeah
and they know the number and they refuse
to answer it and then say there are no
data and and so
how do you fix it i think one way to fix
it is getting rid of the special
immunity from liability that big tech
has that congress gave them
so that's 2 30 right that's 2 30. okay
and the reason
230 was passed congress believed big
tech would be
a a neutral public forum
in other words it wasn't fair to sue
facebook for a comment made by
an individual commenter because it
wasn't they weren't the speaker it was
someone else and so that was
that was congress's reasoning so we're
going to give big tech this immunity
from liability because it's third party
speakers and we want to see the internet
grow
well what's happened is big tech changed
their mind they said we're not going to
be
to use the the language of the google
document
the the lays a fair free speech place
anymore we're going to censor well you
know what if they're going to silence
views they disagree
and promote views they agree with they
don't
deserve i don't believe as a public
policy matter a special protection for
liability
there's also the antitrust laws google
is a monopoly
by any measure big tech is richer
stronger more powerful than a t was when
it was broken up under the antitrust
laws they're bigger than b
than u.s steel was uh a line from the
godfather we're bigger than u.s steel
well they're bigger than u.s steel
um and
that abuse of power so i've also you
want to talk about the real
what the trump administration did on
section 230 will be
challenged it's at the fcc there'll be
litigation
the real bite here is
federal antitrust litigation which which
i have
urged the president to pursue diverge
the vice president pursue i've urged the
attorney general to pursue i've urged
the chairman of the federal trade
commission to pursue i've urged the
white house chief of staff to pursue
i've urged the white house council to
pursue to to
force the transparency to get the
answers
and to stop their their their naked bias
are you worried though that as
we sit here right now in the middle of
july only you know three four months
before an election that insert in a
certain way that the ship has already
sailed the damage that they've done
and even if you could get everything you
wanted tomorrow past tomorrow
by the time the processes and the
systems are are
implemented congratulations the
elections passed
uh i am deeply worried about it one
at one of the hearings i chaired we had
testimony from a guy
named named dr epstein oh yeah i know
about it um
and he's a psychologist used to be the
editor of psychology today
he's an academic he's by the way not a
conservative he's a liberal democrat
who voted for hillary clinton and openly
supported hillary clinton and and he did
empirical research on google's
manipulative search outcomes so it's
interesting psychology
when you type in a search the
autocorrect
the auto fill in not the autocorrect but
what automatically populates
makes a huge difference
um and the first few stories that come
up make a huge difference and there was
a dramatic differential
between when you typed in hillary
clinton it would auto populate goods
yeah all good things there when you
typed in donald trump it would auto
populate bad things and the stories that
would come up
would be predominantly good stories for
hillary predominantly bad stories
uh for trump and what was interesting is
is
dr epstein did the study and he
concluded that in 2016
google's uh deceptive
search outcomes shifted 2.4
million votes to hillary clinton
and he said this as a hillary clinton
supporter but he was he was horrified
but he also
projected he said in 2015 he said big
tech is getting worse it's getting more
aggressive they could move as many as
15 million votes
to the democrats in 2020 and and so i
think it's a
huge threat so as a sci-fi guy
because i know you're a sci-fi guy in a
certain way doesn't it feel like we're
already
in the dystopian future that we're
always worried about
that so many great movies are about that
in a way we're we're kind of
there already we are
because the power and ubiquity i mean
what makes social media
different look there's all sorts of
biased media outlets the new york times
is ridiculously biased but you but you
can pick it up and you can say okay this
is a
partisan rag and you can know it what is
so
such a game changer with social media is
that it's invisible
so if they don't like what you say you
can post and it just fades into ether
and you don't know
you have no idea so i've got you know
on twitter i think my personal twitter i
think we've got 3.7 million followers i
have no idea to the state i've
asked by the way the ceos when i post
something
what percentage of the people who have
chosen to follow me
see it they won't answer that did you
know that that
shadow banning is actually in the
twitter terms of service
there's a i'll i'll show it to you after
this or my guys can maybe pull it up
and we'll show it right now in their
terms of service when they renewed it on
january 1st because they know nobody's
paying attention
it actually says that they can throttle
accounts and not throttle accounts
so they're telling us in their own terms
of service
that it's in there and then the guys get
up on capitol hill and they tell you we
don't do anything
it is the magnitude of the power
and you know you talk about dystopian
worlds
the hard left and i'm interested dave
say so you used to be a man of the left
and nobody's perfect you're not now yeah
why
i'd be interested in in my audience has
heard it many times but i'll give you
the bumper sticker version
was one day it just
hit me that it could not possibly be
true
that everyone i disagree with is a bigot
and a racist and a homophobe and
i know that sounds almost cliche to say
but every argument of the left
came down to that and i could not
believe
somehow that i was so morally right
about every position that i had come to
and that everyone else was so
ridiculously evil like
it was basically a math equation and i
was like the math doesn't work here
anymore it can't be right
and then the bizarre thing that happened
and i'm sure
four years ago i was saying all sorts of
crazy things about you and i was saying
all sorts of crazy things about rand
paul and a bunch of people
half of that exactly but but a bunch of
but but once you
suddenly look at the other side and you
go holy cow you know these conservatives
these libertarians
they really just want to get out of your
way in in most respects
once you see that it's very welcoming so
it's like i know we have
political disagreements uh we disagree
on abortion for example and i'm more
than happy to talk about it if you want
to but i know that you want to live in
the same country as me
and the left has created this odd thing
where if you don't agree with them on
everything
you're out man and i i just don't want
to have anything to do with that
look i i get that and particularly in
in this time and listen the age of trump
everything has gotten personal and
angry and it's a morality play you know
you have
were so pulled apart but look one of the
differences that i get really
frustrated with the left they are
willing to use
government power to impose their world
view
on everybody and to punish anyone who
dares dissent this is true in the
censorship world this is true
it is at the end of the day the left are
status they believe in government power
you know i'm someone who who cares
deeply about the constitution and bill
of rights and free speech and that means
the right of people who disagree
profoundly with me
to speak and engage and and i agree with
john stuart mill the cure for bad speech
is more speech so don't silence views
you disagree with
engage with them on the merits and
actually have
ideally a civil decent respectful
conversation and you're right you know
immediately starting with
you know if every conversation begins
with your klansmen that that sort of
dampens the next step of the
conversation yeah but you don't get much
further than that
yeah i gotta show you i have a copy of
on liberty in my nightstand so
i'm with you on that all right i'm gonna
tell you something very funny so you and
i before the show we're talking about
houston rockets and i'm a die-hard
houston rockets fan
one of the stranger things i own when i
was
i think i was in college and i was on an
airplane
and hakeem olajuwon i already i already
loved this story where everybody
he was he was sitting up in first class
i was back in the cattle car he was up
up as a time when i guess nba players
didn't fly private
everywhere but it was he was sitting
there right and i was sort of star
struck
and so i went up and asked for his
autograph but the only thing i had as i
was reading
john stuart mills on liberty that's
incredible and i had a red pen
that i was underlining it with so i've
got it home i'm not sure where it is
which is but i have a
hakeem olajuwon number 34
signed on on the the title page of of
jon stewart mills
you literally have my whole life in a
book basically that that's absolutely
absolutely incredible that i told you
that 95 rockets team is my my favorite
team of all time all right so wait a
second so let's
let's push a little further on so
because the left wants to use
state power in a way that generally
speaking the right doesn't want to or at
least that you don't want to
if we're to go on this dystopian future
idea are you worried that
if these guys really take power i mean
they're going to start jailing political
opponents they are going to
use we know they've already used the irs
to do all sorts of crazy things
i mean these are things that are sort of
conspiracy theories and then suddenly
at this point nothing feels like a
conspiracy theory but
it's all justified
in the in there's a self-righteousness
to it
we're right anyone who disagrees is evil
therefore anything is justified to
suppress the evil
you see that with cancer culture where
people go
like get driven out
out of the public discourse look when i
was
in college i was a college debater yes i
was one of the cool kids um
but so i was in college i was the
the chairman of the conservative group
in in the debate
debate society and and one of my closest
friends was the head of the liberal
group and we would have arguments about
free enterprise and socialism like what
works
what actually benefits humanity and
actually that question's an important
question
too often people start with the
assumption the other side wants humanity
to suffer
if we start with the premise okay most
people of goodwill
would like people to be happier and more
well-off and more prosperous we start
with that premise
then we can have a conversation about
okay
what systems produce
more prosperity more opportunity it's
it's you know
a couple of years ago i did three cnn
town hall debates with bernie sanders
and and they were 90 minutes long and
bernie look to bernie's credit he's an
unabashed socialist i disagree with him
but he's honest
and we can have a conversation about you
know socialism i think if you look
across the world
it doesn't work it's produced misery
poverty suffering
death you know my family fled cuba
and so i'm more than happy to take the
american free enterprise system
or as the left derisively calls it
capitalism
and put it up next to communism or
socialism or any dictatorship they've
implemented in
every any country on earth and people
are better off they have more
opportunity and
in particular there's the mobility
you know you look at the dystopian um
dystopian worlds one of the elements of
it is everyone is frozen in their place
socialist countries communist countries
there are rich people
they're powerful people what you don't
see is new rich people what you don't
see
you know when my dad in 1957 was a
teenage
kid from cuba couldn't speak english
washing dishes making 50 cents an hour
why did he come to america because this
is a country where you could
be a teenage kid washing dishes and
climb
that socioeconomic ladder and it kind of
worked out for his kid
it if someone had told my father
in 1957 that 50 years in the future
his son would be in the senate that
teenage immigrant could never have
believed it and
and that but if we can have
conversations then we can say all right
what works what doesn't work
the left is afraid to have those
conversations their ideas don't work
all right there there's a joke i tell
sometimes which is
how many radical leftists does it take
to screw in a light bulb how many that's
not funny
[Laughter]
like it's like guys just relax like like
like
lighten up and and
you know my i was talking about in
college when when we were debating we'd
go
you know i he called me a fascist i'd
call him a
uh uh a communist then we could get a
beer
like just you know not all of life has
to be
i must destroy my enemy and there's a
lot of that right now but do you think
there's a fundamental reason for that i
think there actually
is that that lefties now
and not always and i actually want to
ask you about what it used to be like
when there was a sort of sane democratic
party
but that there's a fundamental reason
for the the anger
and the outrage and the perpetual
craziness which is
they believe government is everything
and that you know this as a senator it's
a pretty freaking messy
probably often miserable game that you
have to play
to be to be a politician in america or
probably anywhere
and that because their whole world view
is through politics
as opposed to a religious or some other
spiritual worldview
well of course you're going to be
endlessly miserable do you think i'm
ball parking something there
so i do and and it's
you know it's interesting i was talking
the other night
to a gentleman he and his wife came from
cuba and came from
cuba fled under under caster and he was
talking about he said
you know ted you talk about the
constitution quite a bit
and he said i think there are a lot of
people like me who who
came from countries with the
constitution was meaningless
and they don't necessarily understand
why that matters and they're a little
bit skeptical
of what why
should the constitution make a
difference and i was
agreeing with him in that we need to
explain that more
government power the history of humanity
is largely in a history of government
oppressing the people now you need some
government i'm not an anarchist
you need government to to protect your
your fundamental rights
to life to liberty to property john
locke wrote wrote about the
the fundamental natural rights you need
government to impose rule of law
and we see countries that don't have
that are disasters
but the more power government has the
less liberty you have
and jefferson had a great way of putting
it he described the constitution
as chains to bind the mischief of
government
um yeah that's pretty profound yeah
you know free speech
is not about silencing those who
disagree with you
um religious liberty it's not about
forcing everyone to practice your faith
it's about saying look
it's up to you what faith you practice
or none at all that's that's
that right of conscience that you get to
decide that it's not
government that comes in you know you
just had
all right you know you talked about
abortion you and i may disagree on
abortion but you just had joe biden a
week ago
say if he's elected he's coming after
the little sisters of the poor
no i'm completely against that by the
way i mean i've done videos on it yeah
i mean that is an extreme view you
literally have politicians saying
those damn catholic nuns i'm going to go
after them
and force them to
pay for abortion-inducing drugs and
these are nuns who've taken vows of
poverty and helping
the poor and the sick and the needy and
and government now
for years has been persecuting them
because they must conform and and it's
just look i think
being libertarian and living let live
giving people like
respecting diversity
solves a lot of the problems we have in
the country
so so speaking of diversity then do you
ever feel it because you mentioned
your father and your family's story
because you're a republican
because you're on the right that in many
ways the people who
love to scream about diversity all day
long they've sort of stolen that
from you i know you don't wave it as a
as a victim card
but your own personal family story and
and because you're
you look white so to speak and because
you're on the right you're you're
just a white guy congratulations
look i on social media
it is amazing you look at some of some
of the angry protesters
who who sometimes are
angry angry rich white guys
who are telling everyone look the riots
that that occurred following
the horrific killing of george floyd
many of the neighborhoods that were
burned down were african-american
neighborhoods
some of the most poignant and powerful
videos
were of residents they're crying going
okay you just burned my only grocery
store
you know my you know african-american
small business owners whose stores were
destroyed
and destroyed by
self-entitled often
middle or upper class kids look i grew
up
my my mom is irish and italian
from a working class family she was
first person to ever go to college
uh my dad you know as i said was an
immigrant with nothing
when i was in high school my parents
went bankrupt
we we had a small business it was the
mid 80s oil crash
we lost everything we lost our home we
lost ever i mean lost everything so i
went to college at age 17.
my parents couldn't pay any tuition i
was on my own at 17.
and
i'm grateful for a country that led a
kid
now my parents gave me a home with love
and nurturing and so
in that respect i was rich i was rich in
terms of having a mom and dad who loved
me and encouraged me
but you know i was on my own
and that's that's the beauty of this
country and
and
i think the single biggest lie in all of
politics
is that republicans of the party the
rich and democrats of the party the poor
i think it's absolutely false if you
look at democrats today
they are the party of silicon valley
billionaires they are the party
of wall street tycoons they are the
party of
power and resources and and
republicans the party that i want to be
a part of
is a blue collar party we're the party
of
ohio steel workers we're the party of
single moms waiting tables we're the
party of
teenage kids like my dad washing dishes
why
because opportunity is why the ability
of people to
to have a job and to work is powerful
do you see that as the ultimate irony of
what's happened with silicon valley is
that i think privately i mean i know a
lot of these guys
privately they're libertarians of course
they are because they want to create
they love competition and they want to
be tax low so that their businesses can
thrive
and then publicly what you see them say
is completely the reverse
well look i mean silicon valley is so
bad that
you know peter peter um yeah peter has
been a buddy of mine for
for 25 years we're friends too peter and
i were friends
before he he had made his money um when
peter and i became friends it was the
mid-90s and he was a
corporate lawyer practicing law um
silicon valley is so bad that peter was
driven out of it i mean he's moved down
los angeles like like it it uh
you know something's wrong when you're
coming to la for a safe haven from the
left
it's and and there's
big tech is about power and and it's
also
about
virtue signaling it's about showing that
you're morally
self-righteous um
and when they're driving someone like
peter thiel out saying you
are a heretic and and it's it's on
view after view after view that there is
you know it's interesting
it's a religious fervor it's become
the new religion wokeness is and and by
the way
no one can be too pure like like it i i
mean there's an element of like
robosphere setting up the
the the guillotine where they will come
after if someone is only
99 woke well the 1
is coming after that yep and and that
well we see that with all with all these
hollywood people right because no matter
how much they beg
they think it's going to spare them but
it's not going to be the angry trump
supporters who come to burn down their
mansions
it's going to be these other guys no
matter what penance you offer them but
that sort of gets back to what i was
asking you before about do you think
that because the world
view is bereft of anything other than
politics that the whole it leaves
actually
it leaves you with you know what people
would say is a god-shaped hole that
they're
that they there is no sort of spiritual
anything there
so you become you become the very thing
that you hate in essence
yeah i'm not sure big tech hates it all
that much so so i actually think
you know tech started out as
uh you know and and by the way my
parents are both mathematicians
and computer programmers so i mean i was
raised in
in a techy world their small business
was a seismic data processing
company my parents were programming i
mean my mom
started as a program in 1956 right i
mean really the dawn of computers
i think tech started out you had people
let's say a mark zuckerberg
drops out of college goes and starts
facebook you know who they're just
trying to build a business and they're
doing their own thing and and and
big tech didn't start out all that
political it was
go you know hey you know play foosball
in the office and
and you know wear shorts and flip-flops
and go innovate and be disruptive
you know the whole disrupter thing is a
big part of the ethos
and early on i i don't see silicon
valley as as deeply political
it it's more recently
and it's
it's it's a clothing of protection for
one thing
these guys are the modern-day robin
barretts i mean the
vast amount of wealth as these
plutocrats
live in you know their their
owning islands and flying massive jets
and
and just they've got walls around those
houses don't they they have that
and security with guns and it all
becomes
just i actually don't think they care
that much about this
but they don't want to be rejected by
the mob
i i think it's much more a protective
shield and
the world of social media becomes
self-reinforcing where
you know we used to have homogenizing
[Music]
institutions of whether it was church or
school
or the rotary club where you know
you might be a democrat but you knew
some republicans you might be a
republican you knew some democrats
uh you might be christian or jewish or
muslim but you knew people of different
faiths and
and it was not on social media now
anyone who disagrees
gets unfriended and it becomes this echo
chamber where everyone has
the same view and and when i look at our
democracy i
what i worry about is there aren't
shared facts anymore we're not
the left is listening to left-wing
websites they're listening to their own
facts the right is listening to
right-wing
websites by the way look fox is every
bit as one-sided as biased
as msnbc is and neither one of them are
actually like
have having an objective conversation
that i worry about what that's doing to
our country do you ever get invited on
msnbc anymore um
i haven't been in a while i mean i've
done chris matthews
he's gone he's gone yeah they drove him
out you're right
it it so the last time you were invited
by the guy who they took out
the last time i did it chris hayes
interviewed me we did a thing
called trib fest the texas tribune does
this big so i did an hour interview and
i
agreed to that and we actually had a
good actually that was a good
substantive conversation um it was about
an hour long and it
you know look he came at me pretty hard
which is fine i mean that
if we're having a conversation that's a
step in the right direction
so do you miss i mean i think i know the
answer is but do you
miss sort of the same blue dog
more centrist democrat because i think
biden was the last hope
of that thing that's what it strikes me
as and clearly he's not going to be the
savior obviously for many reasons
but you know jordan peterson talks about
this a lot that you want this healthy
tension between the left and the right
and it's like look i know i'm new to the
right so maybe i don't see some of the
problems that you guys have been around
so you see
but what i see is this pretty diverse
group of the real trump people the more
libertarian people
uh that are all that are all sort of
trying to fight for what the future is
on the left i just see purging do you
miss the old school you know i know jfk
is before your time but do you miss an
old-school democrat daniel patrick
moynihan yes
yeah look jfk is a great example
scoop jackson on foreign policy who who
believed in standing up to communists
that
that that uh you look at jfk i i
often quote jfk you you read his
speeches for example what he says
on uh on religious liberty you read his
speeches on cutting taxes
where he campaigned in 1960 on we're
going to cut your taxes and we're going
to cut your taxes that's going to
produce more jobs
more prosperity that's going to benefit
everyone
those speeches he would be driven out of
the democratic party like some
crazy heretic today yeah um
you look at the tax cut we passed in
2017
you know how many democrats voted for in
the house
zero zero in the senate zero
there was nobody i'll give you another
example one one that
the media refused to cover but it's one
that i'm i got very passionate about
the democrats introduced a
constitutional amendment in the senate
to repeal the free speech protections of
the first amendment
now this was following the citizens
united case which citizens united has
become this totem
so hillary clinton pledged every justice
i appoint is going to repeal citizens
united
joe biden said the same thing um do they
know when they say that about what the
supreme court
nominees are going to do in the future
that that's not really how government
works
well i mean every everyone does this
across the world
for democratic nominees it largely does
yeah so i've got a book that's coming
out
uh in october called one vote away and
it talks about how one vote on the
supreme court uh
can can change history and it goes
through the history on the left so on
citizens united
citizens united by the way like a lot of
people don't know what the case was
about it was about a movie maker
who made a movie critical of hillary
clinton
and the obama administration wanted to
punish the movie maker
for daring to criticize hillary clinton
and the democrats introduced a
constitutional amendment the first
version of the constitutional amendment
would have given the federal government
what's called plenary power plenary is a
legal term that just means
blanket broad the whole damn thing
plenary power
to regulate any expenditure of money for
political speech
that would mean um if a little old lady
spent five dollars on a poster board and
a stick and put it in her front yard
saying vote for joe biden or vote for
donald trump
congress could make that a crime that
would mean by the way look we're sitting
here in a room where you've bought this
furniture you've got tv cameras there
this is expending money
that would mean congress could regulate
[Music]
with total impunity so we debated it
extensively in the senate i asked
i asked democrats on judiciary committee
three questions
should congress be able to ban movies
should congress be able to ban books
and should congress be able to ban the
naacp naacp is a corporation so their
second version
said we'll just give them total power
over corporations well
corporations aren't people they're
collections of people
my answer to those three questions are
no no and hell no
when we voted on it do you know that
every single democrat in the senate
voted to repeal the free speech
protections of the first amendment
i mean there used to be liberals used to
defend
that there's there's a famous case that
went to the supreme court
um where a guy wore into a courthouse a
jacket
that said f the draft although he didn't
abbreviate it
and went all the way to the supreme
court and the supreme court rightly
upheld his right to
to wear that and and you know one of the
justices said
one man's obscenity is another man's
lyric
there are none of those liberals left in
politics there are a handful
in the world but in politics
they're they don't believe in free
speech anymore and that's
that's scary can i give you the star
wars reference that you can use for this
going forward
it's order 66. that's what the
progressives did
they executed order 66 on the liberals
and they hunted them down
and there's a couple in hiding bill
maher maybe three or four other guys
what would have been formerly me i would
say and and that's kind of that's kind
of where we're at now
it's you are right and
look yoda escaped i i like that
that has you yeah hiding out but but it
there is a rapid intolerance
so the left demands conformity and you
think about it socialism
socialism is about the government being
in charge of everything
that demands total conformity
um you take something like federalism
i'm a massive believer
believer in federalism we have 50 states
who would expect california to adopt the
same laws as texas
and that's okay i look i that's why we
have 50 states you can choose i
think the laws of each state should
reflect the values so let's take
something like
drug legalization so personally speaking
i'm not in favor of drug legalization
but i think it's a state question i
think it's perfectly fine for different
states to come to different answers on
it and
for there to be a diversity and
to see what works the left doesn't like
that diversity
and i'll give you an example here's
here's a question very few people ask
socialized medicine so it's become the
new
mantra that everyone has to support
socialized medicine medic care for all
there are 50 states in the union how
many have adopted socialized medicine
is it maybe three is it zero is it what
about massachusetts didn't they do
something no
no they did romneycare which was the
predecessor to obamacare
but let's take california california
there's a democratic governor a
democratic supermajority in the
legislature
they could adopt socialized medicine
tomorrow
you know why they didn't because they
ran the numbers and it bankrupted the
state
right well when obama had a super
majority himself as president he didn't
do it
it vermont bernie sanders is home state
they don't have socialized medicine
here's part of the reason why if
california adopted it and there's
nothing
republicans can't stop them it is the
democrats who have decided we that we
should not have socialized medicine in
california and the reason is
the taxes they would have to impose
would crush small businesses even more
it would cause them to flee the state
to move to texas so so what does the
left want to do
here's our solution let's impose it on
the whole damn country so you can't flee
unless you're willing to go to new
zealand yeah if you're going to stay in
the united states
there's no place to go my view look
under the constitution if california
wants socialized medicine
knock yourself out i think it's a bad
policy but prove me wrong go
show me that it works but it it is the
view
everyone must conform
that i think is really dangerous so you
mentioned the
uh debates that you had with bernie
sanders the couple on cnn i saw them and
when people say to me well dave you seem
so different politically than you did
five years ago i always say the one
thing that i really did shift on
was economics so i'm way more right
libertarian on economics
most of the other things actually i
still believe i'm standing up for my my
true liberal beliefs not the way
liberalism has been butchered now um
when when you had those debates with him
do you think bernie
now slightly regrets what he has
unleashed here because i think you could
look at the crazed marxist lunacy
and the squad and identity politics and
the hatred of america i mean every
every bernie debate what was it we're
going to have i mean he kept saying
political revolution because he knew if
he
just said revolution that means heads on
spikes which that's coming but
give it a little while um but do you
think he maybe regrets
some of what he has led to here or do
you think he's just
riding it out now i'm also i will say
one other thing which is i'm a firm
believer they will take him out too
because eventually he will just be an
old failed white guy who played by the
system
played by everyone i don't think he
regrets it so bernie is a true believer
um and and and i prefer
honesty um a lot of democrats for a long
time pretended they weren't socialists
even though they voted like it bernie's
changed that party and
changed that party dramatically and
look i think bernie is grumpy that he's
not
the savior that he wanted to be so
look a lot of revolutionaries
in cuba fidel castro was about phil
castro he wanted the power to be the
dictator
i think bernie is unhappy you know
there's a particular kind of bitterness
you look at how bernie deals with saying
elizabeth warren
yeah who is a you know younger
interloper and both of them look at aoc
and go who the hell are you
now they they're all on the same team
but it's sort of
except i don't think i agree he's a true
believer but i don't think he had like
this sort of
true true fundamental hatred of all of
our institutions
aoc ilhanomar are the others now again i
i'm not saying i'm totally right about
this
but i sense like a real like let's
destroy the whole damn thing
with them then i think bernie was the
was the thing that allowed it into the
system well and you look at for example
let's take
statues that are being torn down so so
the debate started
with confederate statues and and we can
have a conversation about that
look i'm one that believes we shouldn't
erase history but
but i also believe
slavery is the original sin of america
it is a grotesque evil
and our nation fought a bloody civil war
where six hundred thousand people died
to end slavery and our journey to civil
rights
it has been a long journey it's been an
imperfect journey
we continue on that journey but but as
as
dr martin luther king said the arc of
history bends towards justice
but it started out as a discussion of
confederate monuments
then it became a discussion of george
washington of thomas jefferson
of james madison uh it became people
defacing
statues of abraham lincoln and ulysses s
grant because you know they were such
big confederates yeah frederick douglass
so the ignorance of it frederick
douglass
like the angry mob at some point
when you're attacking washington and
lincoln and frederick douglass
it's not that you hate slavery it's not
that you hate racism
you hate america but so what i'm trying
to figure out though when i see today's
democrats it's even pelosi when she's
now
nodding to them like oh well people have
legitimate grievances and
it's like i don't think she believes it
but she's just trying not to get her
mansion burned down like do you
do you think it's that bad like it seems
to me that that's obvious at this point
i
i think it it is
there's a video i saw on twitter of
uh some college kids i think they were
in new york and there was a riot and
then
we're on your side you were on your side
i mean it was
it was no no don't burn us down yeah so
they throw the rock through their window
and they're supposedly cheering them on
and it's like nobody's there's no side
because it's a
and you look at look
you look at the angry marxists
who want to destroy this country and and
i
worry i worry about our education that
people don't understand
what we have in america is unique in the
history of the world
um most of history
look free speech free speech doesn't
exist in many countries on earth today
and we're not training our kids to
to know to understand the degree to
which
they're just being told everything is
systematically racist you know we just
had a
debate in the senate judiciary committee
where all these democrats are saying
nothing has changed in 50 years i'm like
what utter garbage nothing has changed
we had jim crow laws we had we had
segregated schools with segregated
water fountains we you're saying the
march ensemble didn't do any didn't do
anything i mean that
that is and the problem is it's a lie
if people don't understand the journey
towards justice towards protecting
people's rights
then they want to burn it all down which
ends up hurting everybody's right so
okay so the obvious question there is
are the two as we watch now mainstream
media burn down
and the institutions burn down so you're
you're a harvard guy you're a princeton
guy
these are institutions that are on fire
right now
i i would say rightfully so the new york
times
rightfully so the 1619 project let this
thing
freaking burn the amount of hit pieces
that they've done on me that they've
done
on people in my circles that i'm sure
they've done on you
but are you worried that if all of these
liberal in the right sense of liberalism
institutions burn down that we will have
nothing that will allow us for national
cohesion because you sort of hit on that
earlier yeah
i'm deeply worried about it um they're
no longer liberal in any real sense of
the word they are authoritarian
the new york times fired their editor
because he dared write an op-ed
from a u.s senator yeah no he didn't
write it he just allowed it to be
published
yeah yeah we think about for the for a
second and look actually
you know look the the the op-ed that tom
cotton wrote it was okay i actually
didn't agree with a lot of the stuff he
said i thought it was a
a bit a bit much
but if you disagree with it write
something saying it's wrong like like
why are you part of it is
it's a testament of fear you don't
believe in your own ideas
um free speech and by the way you hear
people in the senate all the time say
well
speech that's offensive shouldn't be
allowed
that's exactly what the first amendment
is about it
you don't need the first amendment for
speech that everyone agrees with if the
majority agrees with it
you don't need the first amendment to
protect your rights to say puppy dogs
are nice yeah
that that's that's like at least right
now nobody is stopping the pro puppy dog
patience patience you know supreme court
in another famous decision skokie
illinois
the nazis wanted to march supreme court
rightly said you've got a right to march
now by the way when it comes to nazis
i'm perfectly happy to say they're evil
ignorant bigoted morons
and i'm not scared of them saying
whatever idiocy they want to say because
now i think we have a moral obligation
to engage in it to say why it's wrong
but but
government shouldn't silence them you
know why should we be afraid of the klan
the clan are idiots
and we need to demonstrate why what
they're saying is wrong
but inevitably the mob calls everyone a
nazi or klansmen
and they use it to justify regulating
you know jk rowling now can't say
women exist that that is deemed the same
as adolf hitler okay that's just
a little nuts like like like we can have
a
a respectful civil conversation but
you're right
there are no
walter cronkite used to report on now
look cronkite leaned
left but not in a
virulently partisan way and
some of it is the media trump broke the
media
yeah but like they hate him so much
there is no longer there used to be
five years ago
the media pretended they're impartial
remember they would argue there is no
bias in media
have you heard anyone make it nobody
says that anymore because it's so
obvious that they've decided we're not
they no longer hold out
impartiality as an objective to which
when the new york times
because impartiality is now proof that
you're somehow racist or something like
that
the six year upholding project is a
fundamentally racist bigoted endeavor
and the new york times admits to
redefine
history and the real danger of the 1619
project is going to be all the little
tyranny of leftists
in the school boards that begin teaching
in schools that this is
propaganda uh that that that is
of orwellian proportions so senator cruz
are you telling me that the united
states didn't invent slavery
we didn't invent slavery i mean we we
also got rid of it pretty quickly they
don't really want to get that and it was
going on for
thousands and thousands of years and
it's still going on in parts of the
world
somehow that's inconvenient and and
listen the
abolitionists s so
one of the rich ironies is the democrats
who moralize on questions of race
the democratic party is an absolute
freaking
train wreck on race the democrat it was
democrats who founded the kkk
it was democrats who wrote jim crow
it was democrats who implemented
segregation
the party i'm a member of the
republicans was
founded to oppose slavery abraham
lincoln was the first republican
president the
reason we were founded now here's the
democratic narrative
well yes that was true then nathan
bedford forrest who's the founder of the
kkk
he's a delegate to the democratic
national convention in 1860.
the the the media narrative is yes that
was then but but the democrats
changed well interesting let's go to the
civil rights act in 1964.
a lot more a lot higher percentage of
republicans supported that than
democrats did
it was the dixiecrats bull connor was a
democrat
the the guys with the dogs and the clubs
beating the civil rights protesters
without exception were democrats and
they said well okay
fine that's true up to the 60s but
magically it changed
dave right now today as we sit here the
sitting governor of virginia
chose to put in his yearbook a picture
of a klansman and it may or may not have
been him
yeah now think of the pathology of the
media for a second so ralph northam
who's a democrat he's an elected
democrat today
not 50 years ago not a hundred years ago
today in 2020
he put in his yearbook a picture
of one guy dressed as a klansman or
another guy in black face
now what an indictment of the media that
everyone freaked out about the blackface
now look
all right i can accept that blackface i
i can understand why that would be seen
as disrespectful
i think the media is a little freaked
out about it like every late night comic
is dressed in blackface
i and i don't think it was a big deal in
texas i don't think i've ever known
anyone who's dressed in blackface it
seems like in virginia
every elected politician just about did
it
but it was weird that between the two
they had this this
this hysterical fit about the black face
and no one comments about the clan
outfit and ralph northam's comment the
day after it broke it was the most
revealing it was before they had gotten
their their talking points down
he said he acknowledged that he could
have been one of those two people and he
didn't say which one
[Music]
if you're in elected office and you
cannot say categorically i have never in
my life dressed as a klansman
you talk about canceled culture as far
as i'm concerned vote if you don't know
if you've been a klansman
i'm more than prepared to vote yet off
so is that trump's greatest skill
because you guys went at it pretty hard
in 2016 and now you've become one of i
would you i would say you're one of his
biggest allies in the senate um
but you guys were going after each other
and said a lot of
mean stuff about each other and all that
but would you say his greatest skill
is that well you said it earlier that he
broke the media but that he
broke the inequity in the system
the inequity in the system meaning that
culture just teaches
everybody you're a republican you're a
conservative you're on the right you're
bad
you're a democrat you're a lefty
whatever you're good and that trump
broke the whole damn thing and that that
is why we're all kind of crazy right now
but but in my view at this point it was
a necessary
move yeah so yes i think there are a
couple of things i think
one by the way we've been talking for
almost an hour we only said trump like
twice i think we just set some sort of
record here that's that's pretty
impressive
look i think 2016 was a giant screw you
to washington
i think working class voters were fed up
with washington
you won't understand the 2016 election
it's blue collar workers across the
country there's a reason
why in 2016
trump and i in almost every state in the
primary
either he was one and i was two with
blue-collar voters or i was one and he
was two and it's almost perfectly
correlated the states where i was one
and he was two
are the twelve states i won the states
where he was one and i was two of the
states he won and no other republican
won more than a single state
it was a blue-collar revolution who even
won one besides kasich one ohio okay
rubio won minnesota trump and i won the
other 48.
and by the way i remember at the
beginning there were 17 republicans
conventional wisdom
if you were ranking those 17
nobody in washington or new york would
have said trump had a chance and no one
said i had a chance we might have been
16 and 17 on the
ordinal rankings of of who had a shot
right and by the way you had men women
black people latinos white people
the whole thing what did they have on
the other side remember reporters
i was in south carolina and i was doing
a press gaggle and a bunch of reporters
said
what do you do about the fact that
republicans are a bunch of old white
guys
and i stopped and just started laughing
and i said number one
have you looked at the democratic field
they're literally
septigenarian socialists all of them
i do you know how many hispanics have
ever won a presidential primary in the
democratic party
a presidential primary well i'm guessing
zero a state i'm talking about
even a single state i'm going to guess
it's zero
yeah you know julian castro was
complaining that you know
that you know we shouldn't have iowa
voting because no because no hispanic
can win
well i pointed out look you look at the
2016
field we've got an african-american
world-famous
neurosurgeon we've got a woman who was a
ceo of a fortune 50 company
we've got two sons of cuban immigrants
who are
in their 40s i mean you want to talk
about like
but the press still described us as old
white guys
right and the old white guys who were
socialist at their bolshevik reunion
as somehow you know elizabeth warren
just just
said we need new leaders do you know joe
biden you know when joe biden was sworn
into the senate 37 years ago something
crazy
1973 i was two when joe biden took his
oath of office he's been presiding over
an awful lot of problems
do you find it hilarious then when as
the primary was rolling out the
democratic primary that every time
someone that was a minority or a
perceived minority dropped out they
basically said that their own party was
racist they would say well we're not
diverse enough
it's like well it's your base that's
voting you guys out you can't blame this
but somehow the media spins it that you
suddenly like oh i guess the republicans
are racist
it's facts don't matter for their
narrative they are
it is a propaganda effort so i think the
trump election in 2016 was number one to
screw you to washington
number two it was working-class voters
um
under obama the democratic party made a
choice it was a very conscious choice
between two traditional favored children
of the democratic party you were talking
about
the old democrat where there were blue
dog democrats
the democrats made a choice between
california
environmentalist billionaires
and the jobs of labor union members now
look the democratic party used to be fdr
it used to be the working man the union
party
and under obama the party decided it
wanted the money
from the tom steyers of the world more
than it wanted
the steel workers and the truck drivers
in pennsylvania
to have jobs and so they consciously and
their view was the union bosses will
deliver the votes
those used to be our foot soldiers we're
going to vote to shut down the keystone
pipeline screw the jobs okay those guys
don't get jobs
because it makes us feel better as as we
are living in multi-million dollar
mansions and it doesn't affect our life
it makes us feel better to give away
their jobs
i think the working-class roar
back at washington was a big part of
2016 and i also think
look it's interesting the i don't think
the phrase cancel culture existed in
2016. it was called
political correctness but the fact that
trump would say
would stand up and speak out and he'd go
around the gatekeepers
it's why social media has gotten more
vigorous they're mad that anyone got
around the gatekeepers so they're trying
to
close off the avenues of communication
okay so i know we're crunched on time
here and i want to get a couple
video game minutes in with you so we'll
try to do this quick so do you think
and i don't mean this as a shot to you
but do you think trump the reason trump
won was because he was willing to do
stuff that you would not have done
because i think there's a sense of that
remember there was that moment when
marco rubio tried it for a day
there was literally that one it didn't
work and it just blew up in his face but
but do you think
and maybe that's not a shot to you or
it's i don't know if it's credit to
trump or just a it has something to do
with how we're all wired or something
like that so you know
in authenticity doesn't work people can
can smell it when you're a fake
yeah uh trump won the primary in 2016
because the media gave him three billion
dollars in free media
and it has no precedent in the history
of politics
three billion dollars in free media but
do you think that was because he was
willing to do something meaning just
blow apart the system i actually think
it was fundamental corruption on the
part of the media
so i think the mainstream media abc cbs
nbc cnn msnbc
they all wanted hillary to win and they
believed trump was the easiest candidate
for hillary to be
and i think they made a very conscious
decision
all trump all the time because they
wanted hillary to win i think they were
corrupt
i think that they had that same
corruption but
the consequence i mean we've had over
two centuries of politics there's never
been a candidate where
three billion dollars of free media it
it became a
tsunami that in the last 30 days there
was 500 million dollars of free media
and
and we couldn't be heard anymore and and
and
and i do think people were fed up with
washington and that's what 2016 was was
a statement about that
all right so i said i said two more but
i'm gonna throw in one more extra so
they're still there too
um what what do you make of the never
trump crew like this lincoln project
these people who are now supporting all
democrats and
now we're talking about it's not just
about taking out trump anymore now it's
out we're gonna find the congressional
candidates
and the candidates in the senate what do
you make of these people who
trump like him don't like him orange big
hair it's like he's doing the things
that conservatives want done
so whenever anyone tells you it's not
about the money
it's about the money look these lincoln
lincoln project guys are a bunch of
political operatives who are making
millions who also got everything wrong
always
forever bill crystal look look that they
have been
they've been operatives for a long time
so
you want to look at the pattern they've
run a lot of losing presidential races
losing to democrats they're very good at
losing to democrats
in significant part you look at all of
these guys so i
think the real divide we have is not
racial it's socioeconomic
it is the difference between
wealthy elites and working class voters
all of these so-called anti-trump folks
are the people who've been saying screw
you to the working-class voters for 20
years
and they're still echoing that and by
the way i think now they're just making
a buck though i mean
that they're printing money to put money
in their own bank account
and listen when it comes to trump
there are a lot of things trump says and
does i don't like
um i agree with many of the policies
he's implemented and i think he's shown
real backbone
and the role i've tried to play the last
four years is is to encourage the
president to go
in a positive direction to encourage him
let's take social
media you know this order i had been
urging the administration for three
years for them to do this so i'm glad
they did and it took a lot of work
and i'm grateful i'm grateful
as a president i think his best
characteristic is that he has a backbone
he's willing to make decisions
that many republicans wouldn't make
things like
moving our embassy in israel to
jerusalem i urged him to do that both
the state department defense department
didn't want him to do that they argued
against it his own state department
defense department
and every president had run on saying
they were going to do it for democrats
and republicans had broken that promise
over and over again
pulling out of the iran nuclear deal
again
state and defense said don't do it i
urged him to do it he did it look that
took balls yeah i'm grateful for that
do i wish he didn't say
didn't send some ridiculous tweets of
course i do
um there are times when
it ends up being less effective
but you know on capitol hill the
reporters run to you and they want to
comment on every tweet
and i tell them i said look i have a
rule of thumb i don't comment on tweets
because i'm not interested in just
playing media pundit and responding to
you know at 10 07 am the president
tweeted this at 109 am
i don't need to do that let's you want
to talk about substance let's talk about
free speech let's talk about religious
liberty let's talk about the second
amendment
let's talk about securing the border
let's talk about rebuilding our military
i'll talk about substance
but and i think in substance we've
gotten a lot done
all right so now i got one more for you
we did we did now 70 some odd minutes my
guys are going to shoot me and i know
you got to get over to craig are you
after this
um we didn't talk about covet at all so
if you could just kind of couch
like how you're feeling we're doing at
this very moment
the states rights part of this and and i
guess most importantly this will be a
sort of
a good ending do we ever get out of this
phase this thing that we're all feeling
right now between covid between the
protests between the oncoming election
do we ever get out of this thing and
back to something that
feels more normal or is to bring it back
to sci-fi
are we heading to a brave new world a
dystopian future
something like that yes we'll come out
of this
how about a question like that when you
only have like three minutes left but
you do
do what you got to do this actually
connected to where we started
this is a good good place to wrap up
about how polarized and tribalized we
are
one of the things i find bizarre about
this pandemic is how
people look look at it through a
political lens it's
all politics so you know my view
on on the virus it's serious
it's deadly we need to take serious
steps to combat
it and i've laid out a whole series of
steps and been advocating for it whether
it's increased testing
whether it's investments in vaccines and
treatments
that we need to use common sense to stop
the spread of the virus
but at the same time people's jobs
matter 44 million people losing their
jobs that produces
real suffering it produces death and you
talk about mental illness and depression
alcohol substance abuse
destroying people's livelihoods is a
problem we need to balance
and what's weird is the idea of balance
the idea of let's
use some common sense it feels kind of
lonely
saying that because all right let's take
for example masks
masks have become this bizarre virtue
signal
um so listen on the right there's some
people like never wear a mask no matter
what
i'm like okay that seems a little out
there
on the left they're democrats who their
social media picture has a mask i
you know i remember one you know sherrod
brown the senator from ohio gave a floor
speech in the senate a couple of weeks
ago
he's wearing a mask during the whole
speech there's no one within 20 feet of
him he's standing alone on the senate
floor with a mask
because it's a sign i am righteous
i am wearing the clothes of the high
priest
now look you and i talked about it i've
got my damn mask in my pocket
houston rockets you didn't make up the
elijah one story um
you know i i believe in you know do
things that are sensible
and use common sense but it
viewing it all through a political lens
by the way i have a prediction
if god forbid biden wins
the day after the election everything
will be better
the day after the election everyone will
say go back to school
go back to work oh the covid at the
covid level
the disease won't suddenly be appeared
right right everyone like the people who
are saying
shut it down there's a political urgency
they want the great depression because
they wanted to defeat trump
if by they won't even wait till biden is
sworn in
if biden is elected that week
they'll say all right everyone needs to
go back to work and go back to school so
you believe they're deliberately tanking
the economy i mean i
i've tweeted that to something to that
effect i believe that gavin newsom here
in california is trying to destroy the
economy so either the feds
have to bail us out or or they hate
trump
so much it's all-consuming and and the
angry left they've convinced themselves
that
donald trump is hitler so everything is
justified
in terms of defeating hitler and it's
it's just like
okay that's and and by the way the
answer
the politicized answer on either side
shut everything down forever or everyone
go back to perfectly normal and don't
you know pretend there's no pandemic
neither one of those
make a lot of sense to me
but listening to medical professionals
and following common sense and also
respecting people's jobs
in the media world who's advocating that
you don't get
if you're not advocating an extreme
position it doesn't exist
senator i feel like we just started here
but it has been 80 minutes
and you've got a busy day ahead of you
but we got to close the way you started
though which is reminding people
to go subscribe to the verdict podcast
either on the podcast
give us a five star rating subscribe
look
verdict podcast as you know we launched
it during impeachment it became the
number one podcast in the world
when we launched it and so come sign on
and what we're doing every week is
having conversations
trying to actually understand what's
what's going on in the world and address
real substance
and have fun too and i'm pretty sure
that that michael knows guys standing on
the other side of that door right now
because we're going to do a little
pickup for ruben report
it was a pleasure i hope you come back
to uh to talk about your book in october
when it comes out excellent
and may the force be with you indeed
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell